and we're really really very pleased to
have Christopher Whitcomb here tonight
with us as you all probably know he's a
veteran with the FBI spent 15 years on
the force and has written his book cold
zero which as we were discussing is more
than about bombs or terrorists or
hostages it's basically one man's
journey and his coming to terms living
in these situations and how these
situations affect him as well as the
rest of our country so I'm very pleased
to bring him here and I'm very pleased
to introduce him and would you all
please welcome mr. Christopher Whitcomb
Thank You Terry I appreciate that
introduction is very kind of you and
thank you all for coming out tonight I
appreciate that very much too I know
it's been pretty tough recently getting
anyone out in the streets at all I just
came back from New York this afternoon
and it's it's very different there than
here even and I know it's very different
here than elsewhere in America because
these two sit cities have suffered so
much so thank you very much for coming
out tonight I should warn you that I do
terribly with podiums and lecterns I'm
allergic to them so if I try to come
around this thing and talk you'll have
to send me that okay well actually I
like going around the other side of it
all right hey whatever you want I think
they need the microphone don't they I'm
getting a wand from the back that they
need the microphone so I'll start
hearing and try this what I'd like to do
tonight
it really is talk about what you want to
talk about because I think this book
sort of blends with many of the the
terrible things that have happened in
the last week and sort of talk about
what's happening in the world what's
happening with the FBI if I can shed
some light on that talk about some of
the things I wrote about in the book and
give you maybe a little bit of a
background a little bit of an idea what
the FBI does what the United States
government does in times of crisis like
this and sort of steer this the way the
way that interests you so what it would
be alright if I just started out with a
little bit about the book why I wrote it
something like that and then just go
where you want to go well cold zero
really started as an accident
this book came about during a
conversation I had with a couple guys in
New York about two years ago I had three
chapters of recollections stuck in a
drawer someplace in my house I had
written a novel in 1992 that I never did
anything with and had thought about
writing another novel but it just put
some of these recollections down and
really forgotten about them but I was
talking to these other gents about
another project entirely was a movie
script ironically that had nothing to do
with these and that conversation turned
to these chapters these chapters turn to
an agent and the agent turned to this
event which is the first book signing
I've gone to one which is an
extraordinary event for me because this
is something I've looked forward to all
my life so I look back on the process
and really have trouble making sense of
it all for any of you that are aspiring
writers for those of you that have
already published that a way ahead of me
maybe some of you you might have looked
at the process and wondered how you get
a book started how you get a book out
how a book gets onto the bookshelves and
when I look back on the process I really
can't figure out what that process was I
my wife's in the back of the room and
she can attest to this story and
originally trying to find an agent for
my first novel I went to everyone I
could imagine and they all gave me the
same thing
you know as a form letter that said
thank you very much for calling us but
you know we have other people to look at
so I eventually hooked up with an agent
in Toronto Canada which when you try to
publish a book in the United States it's
probably not the best idea but that's
all I had to go to so I called her up
she read the book she called me back
which was good because they usually ask
for a self-addressed stamped envelope so
she actually called me on the phone
which I he thought hey I'm making
progress now they called me on the phone
and she said mr. Whitcomb
she's very formal mr. Whitcomb I really
appreciate you calling and sending this
book but I think you should know that I
have a Freudian problem with chicken
farms therefore I could not complete
your book so I thought about I said that
a Freudian problem with chicken farms
which
perhaps some psychologist among you
could help me out with that a little bit
but I did mention the chicken farm at
one point in the book and apparently
that was her way of getting out of
considering the thing any further so
that didn't go very well and that sort
of soured me on the whole process but
then a couple years later it worked out
so I went back I got the contract I went
back and I wrote down recollections I
had from the times in the FBI that I
worked through some of these significant
significant events and they rolled into
a manuscript the manuscript went up to
my editor my editor called back and he
said look we could we'd have to address
a couple of issues here one is that this
story doesn't make any sense
this you have a bunch of recollections
but there's no story here so that was my
my big thing was to go back and turn
what had been some very personal
experiences for me into a story that
might make sense to you and that took I
don't know that took a couple months
later and then finally had to come up
with some kind of a title and I was
thinking about different titles for this
book and really had found myself at a
loss
you know you titling a book especially
now is very difficult because so many
titles have been used you know no no I
won't even go into some that I
considered but Truman Capote's gotten a
lot of them and Hemingway got a lot of
them and you know they'd pretty much
milk the Bible for all the great lines
in there and they're a considerable
number but they seem to have been taken
so I sat down and looked at what the
book weren't represented to me what I
really wanted to try and do in the book
and what I really wanted this book to be
though some will argue and I and I
embrace argument and discussion but what
I really wanted to do with the book was
try and portray things that I had seen
and that I had participated in in a way
I hadn't seen done before which was the
way I what I considered a truthful
representation and those boiled down
into two major events which were Ruby
Ridge in Waco which had two of the most
controversial and hotly contested events
in law enforcement history and probably
fairly significant events in American
history no one from the FBI had talked
much about those events because they
they the FBI seemed loath to bring up
these sorts of subjects and to deal with
them the the line at the FBI when I you
know
all the years that I worked there was
don't worry about what the meteorite the
American people know what happened and
you know they'll everything will be okay
well look if the American people know
what happened based on what they read
and what they see on television what
they hear on the radio and things like
that how can you expect them to know
anything else or how can you expect them
to feel anything else so years went by
things that had been written became fact
and representations made became reality
and and I got to a point in writing this
book where I thought I I hope I get a
chance to change some of those things so
if you bring any presuppositions here
tonight maybe we could discuss them and
maybe I could talk you into at least
considering some other alternative some
other some other possibilities anyway so
I sat down and said well how do I turn
that into it into the title of a book
and what I came up with was a sniper's
term and a sniper's term for hitting
your mark came from two words the cold
bore shot which is pulling a rifle up
out of its case and lying down behind it
and taking a shot with no warm-up in no
practice that's referred to as the cold
bore shot the zero or finding your zero
for marksman among you is when you align
this the crosshairs of your scope with
the impact of your bullet you take a
rifle you put a scope on it and they
don't have you you have no indication of
where they're gonna hit because they're
the two totally different things but
bringing them into alignment through
practice and setting them in so that
your rifle in your crosshairs online
your shot hits where you want to that's
called the zero so you take the cold
bore which is your first shot you take
the zero which is a zero margin for
error you put them too the two of them
together and you come up with a metaphor
for getting it right the first time and
trying to go out and do something and
trying to get it right for the first
time did we always do that in the FBI
the answer is quite obvious no do we
always try the answer in my perspective
anyways yes so cold zero is as much
about my attempts to do things right
during my career during the times I've
seen and the things I've been thrown
into as anything else it's billed as as
tamina said as the you know inside the
hostage rescue team which most people
interpret to be guns and bombs and
things like
and certainly there's some of that but I
think the more you read the book the
more I hope you realize this is about a
journey in this case it happens to be
mine I suppose a journey through some of
these things and that you would get the
idea that you may have some of the same
experiences that you may experience some
of the same emotions that I did because
quite frankly I'm just like you that may
seem odd because you know you could
carry a badge that says FBI and because
I carry a gun or have carried a gun for
15 years
but bottom line is you know I'm no
different than you and I have the same
emotions and I have the same respects
and the same fears and all of those
things and when you put people like me
and like you into extraordinary
situations you come up with some unusual
or you find some unusual things about
yourself so that's a long explanation I
think for a short story which is how I
came up with a story how the book came
about what I hope to do in the book and
what I hope you'll find interesting if
anything in the book the rest of it is
about I think what we are going through
right now as a nation we're going
through an extraordinarily different
difficult time in dealing with terrorism
we're going through an extraordinarily
difficult time in dealing with the human
emotions that come with loss and tragedy
and suffering and trauma all of those
things so perhaps I could talk about
some of those aspects which I've
reflected in the book and talk about
some of those things going on right now
and maybe even answer some of your
questions and allay some of your fears
and if I could do that I'd be happy to
so this is a point when authors and
teachers get a big chill down their
spine and they say are there any
questions because if there's no hands at
all then you're really you really in a
lot of trouble Ferg
for the remainder okay sir thank you how
would you feel when Janet Reno's
performance as Attorney General with
regard to Ruby Ridge and with regard to
Waco where she's vanished
but how would i look at Janet Reno's
performance during Ruby Ridge and Waco
and what do I think of Janet Reno I
think Janet Reno had enormous strengths
as Attorney General of the United States
I think she made an extraordinarily
difficult decision at Waco because he
was just freshly on the job and she had
some really extraordinary circumstances
to deal with
I certainly don't agree with everything
that she did and I think part of what
you realized as you look at this is that
FBI agents like taxicab drivers and
brain surgeons or anybody else in
society have different political views
my political views may not jibe
specifically with Janet Reno's and I
think you know I don't make any bones
about the fact that I that I probably
tended at the time to be a bit more
conservative than Janet Reno in the
Clinton administration
but I will say Janet Reno never shied
from her responsibilities and she never
shied from a decision and I admire that
greatly I respect that a great deal I
felt during the Waco Siege ordeal crisis
well however you wanted however you want
to talk about it that we spent too much
time negotiating and working through
that I know that's a very controversial
thing to say but there was this there
was a very strong sentiment among people
I worked with during the early days of
Waco that had we been allowed by
Washington to do what we were used to
doing we the hostage rescue team we used
to do and we felt that we could have
saved more of the people inside a
considerably more and you know as
tragically most of them perished in that
fire so it was enormous ly frustrating
there was certainly a period after Waco
that became very very difficult and many
things were blamed on Janet Reno my
feeling is that she was brave in making
that decision that at least in some ways
it was the right decision and that I
admired most of what she did during her
time in Washington
I got a couple seeds planted in the back
of the room I think my wife may ask a
question one of my sons or something if
it gets really ugly down here yes ma'am
what sort of response should we expect
after the first military action if we go
after Afghanistan well I think it's
really interesting now that we have a
foregone conclusion that we're gonna
have a military action and I saw that we
are gearing up was it yeah right well I
think it's almost when now but recently
we've just seen today as a matter of
fact that they're moving carrier groups
and lots of resources over to the Middle
East that weren't there specifically in
those places before the climate in
America has changed unlike anything I've
seen in my lifetime certainly during my
career in law enforcement to a point
where America now has changed its
sentiment I I was I went on a show to
remember which one it was because we've
been a couple of Li the Geraldo Rivera
show good I finally got a couple of
people to smile out here a couple
chuckles because that was supposed to be
a joke earlier about the network but uh
but the Geraldo Rivera show with Alan
Dershowitz who espoused in public
proactive assassination Islanders which
is the probably the leading civil
libertarian in the United States a
brilliant man a constitutional scholar
and widely known liberal is that a safe
safe word to say I don't mean not with
any pejorative but I just I think I
think that's a term that he uses
actually at any rate it was very odd to
hear him say two things one that he
backed planned state assassinations and
two that he would offer his defense
services to the prosecution to try and
preempt any defense strategy by anyone
should these people be brought to
justice which I thought was fascinating
but I appointed that only because it
brings up how much the public sentiment
has changed toward this whole situation
to a point where we are getting all
these other countries in line behind a
military response a military strategy
for bringing bin Laden to justice for
bringing some of his associates and I
think there may be some misunderstanding
about how wide-ranging these associates
can be
- I don't know if I'd use the word
punishing but certainly influencing the
Taliban in further dealings with bin
Laden so we are we are certainly gearing
up toward a military response and I
think that the the response will will be
not a cruise missile strike like we saw
with Bill Clinton but it'll be something
much more involved than that and I think
that it's important to point out that I
believe it will dovetail closely with
the criminal investigation being
conducted right now because we've got to
a point now in backing down for a week
or ten days before this thing ends or
next days starts I think where we're
looking at some credible evidence that
our prosecutors can use to justify some
sort of punishment I mean we're not this
is not a knee-jerk reaction it's not a
knee-jerk response this is something
that's calculated that's planned out
that's based on credible evidence and
that will have some appearance anyway of
a justice New York and throughout the
country are there terrorists that are
hidden throughout the country that are
gonna bomb trains and metros well the
question is what kind of response can we
anticipate are there people hiding out
there among us who plan to to react
after that and I and I think you know I
don't want to I don't want to dodge the
question but I think it's very tough to
answer I think it's very very likely
other people in the United States plan
to cause problems I don't think there's
any doubt about that whether they'll do
that whether we respond or not I think
is a safe bet that they will I mean
these people that bomb that the World
Trade Centers in the Pentagon and
crashed that plane in in Pennsylvania
they didn't have to wait for us to to
attack Afghanistan they didn't have to
wait for us to do anything else this was
a preemptive strike on their part
it was a direct provocation it was a
direct act of war in the minds of many
many people and I think it's really
difficult to extend the logic to say if
we retaliate or if we respond that then
they're gonna get really angry you know
it's like when you're a kid well I know
about you guys but when I was a kid and
I'd get in a fight you know and I'd be
dancing around the schoolyard or
something and you'd be boxing a little
bit and he said well you know if you hit
me any harder I'm gonna get really
mad well if I hit him any harder he's
gonna fall down and he was gonna get
back up so I think there's there's
certainly that element that we look at
it and say if we are in fact decline
declaring war on terrorism we have to be
prepared to carry that war to a point
where they won't be able to respond and
that's not just an attack on on
Afghanistan it's not just an attack on
the Middle East it's attacking
figuratively and literally many many
different aspects of this it's changing
laws to change alter maybe expand
intelligence community capabilities and
some of these things that fringe on on
doing away with some of our privacy's
and some of our personal liberties are
we ready for that yet I don't know but I
know there's that people are talking
about that and I know we're getting
close so I'm not worried about a
response from a military attack I'm
worried about a response period and I
think the military attack would would be
a step in the right direction quite
frankly yes sir well our our law
enforcement agencies right now are
someone pregnant you have the Border
Patrol
you have the ATF here you have
various other geisha to the FBI the CIA
and what I've heard in some of the
things to do so some agencies have
warnings of some of these people but
they didn't quite make it through the
chain
you see the more of an amalgamation into
these
agencies in the future more of a
combining
this was yes but I don't give many short
answer so I'll explain that a little bit
I think we definitely need in this
country a quote unquote terrorism's R we
need someone to coordinate the efforts
of all these different agencies most
people don't realize there are 18,000
law enforcement agencies in the United
States alone 18,000 agencies in the
United States which is extraordinary
yes a lot of other countries that was
known as the Ministry of the Interior
which basically controls firstly all the
police
right III don't know that I don't know
that I really back that idea because I
think well and I'll tell you why because
in the United States we have local crime
we have state crime and we have federal
crime that seems odd but murder is a
local crime murder is not a federal
crime unless it occurs on a government
reservation so we have we have a sort of
a tiered approach toward law enforcement
I when I was an agent and I should note
now that I left the FBI on Friday and
I'll explain that a little bit later on
but yeah there's something but the but
there's a tiered response because you
have different violations and federal
violations and local and state
violations always don't even go in the
same place so what we have when we deal
with terrorism is you know a local
infraction for somebody littering but
that litter they leave in the street
could be a bag with a nuclear bomb in it
and then you get the federal and
agencies involved so it makes it very
very difficult to align all of these
different things however federal
agencies working together to provide
intelligence and to share intelligence
and to share information about
individuals need to work together in
order to chase these people down so I do
I do back the idea of bringing all to
get all these groups together under the
leadership of one coordinator but I
think it would be really tough to
stretch that out across the United
States and across the world to bring
everybody together so what I believe
we're going to end up with is someone
who coordinates the efforts of
intelligence and law enforcement
communities and counterterrorism
operations and it includes a much
smaller number of agencies than then
then everyone in the country yes you can
tell us what will be the role of the
hospital
okay the hostage rescue team which I
served on for six years in which I write
about a lot in the book is is a very
little under is a misunderstood and
little-known organization I think the
FBI in the early 1980s actually the the
late 1970s looked at the the Munich
games the Munich terrorist action that
the meet or the terrorist action at the
Munich games and said look if something
like this happens how do we respond to
it and the first answer was while we go
to the army and we go to the Navy we go
to Delta or we go to SEAL Team 6 which
made sense to some people well the
British SAS the 22nd SAS was called to
respond to a place called princess gate
in 1980 where terrorists took over a
Blucas the Iranian embassy and had to go
in use force to free the hostages and in
in the in doing so killed a number of
the terrorists well what they're a
military unit what happened is that one
of the terrorists was not killed so they
brought the terrorists out and they
suddenly said well what do we do with
this fella they didn't have any arrest
authority they didn't have no rules of
evidentiary rules of Criminal Procedure
they didn't know rules of evidence
gathering they didn't have any training
in law enforcement elements so they said
well what do we do now how do we
prosecute what evidence do we have where
did we get the evidence things like that
so the United States government looked
at that and said well if we do a
terrorist incident and we don't kill all
the terrorists what do we do with them
and suddenly we realized that the Posse
Comitatus prevented the use of military
and civilian law enforcement operations
everyone backed up a minute and said who
do we get to do this and the answer was
we don't have anyone so they put
together this idea this group called the
hostage rescue team which started in
1983 January 3rd of 1983 they brought 50
FBI agents who had already been trained
and in all of the things I just talked
about back to Quantico Virginia and they
gave them military training SWAT
training and some specialized training
that they were still developing at the
time they gave them the equipment and
the resources and the time quite frankly
to bring themselves up to speed to be
the
equivalent of these military units so
now you have people who train in the
same tactics have the same gear and
travel in the same circles really as
these military units but they are badge
carrying law enforcement officers in the
United States so that's a reasoning
behind it they put the team together and
they have evolved over the last what is
it 18 years I guess to a point where
they represent the primary
counterterrorism response cell for the
United States government now certainly
Delta and SEAL Team six are
extraordinary groups and I don't mean to
belittle that at all extremely capable
they're warriors and the best in the
world but we don't always need warriors
in a situation in United States and the
hostage rescue team waits for something
less than that is that okay yes the FBI
will be involved in the are the hostage
rescue team is certainly involved in
this crisis on a number of different
areas lots of times they're held in
reserve because quite frankly they're an
insurance policy these guys don't go out
to do SWAT arrest these guys are held in
reserves should everything else fail so
you say well what would fail we very
easily could find one or two or ten of
these these terrorists that are that
people have alleged remain out there in
America somewhere we find them and have
to have to arrest them it's certainly
not going to be an easy thing to do so
they could very easily be called in for
arrest there they may be called in to go
to other countries and bring them back
lots of people don't realize that the
hostage rescue team and the FBI have
traveled to many many different
countries around the world and brought
back terrorists already I don't know
that many people talk about that much
but dating back to the 19th 1980s mid
1980s we went after a fellow named
fellows Eunice was a TWA hijacker and
brought him back to justice in the
United States we brought Mira mal Kanzi
who everyone I think knows in the
Washington DC area thought was Eunice
enough I was Jesus who was a ramzi
yousef Ramzi Yousef was in one of the
most recent so HRT has gone around the
world to bring these people back before
and they may be called to do it here as
well
now
HRT I can't see a role for them in a
military operation but they will
represent the United States interests
anytime we went up against something in
the United States in terms of arrests in
terms of responding to you know another
terrorist crisis something of that
nature so they they have a strong role
right now and they're ready to go as we
speak yes ma'am
but sometimes what happens is they want
was so much to defend
work and effort
is that operating in these
especially mistake
it's a it's a great question talking
about the intelligence and what happens
to you when you get into an organization
things like that I think that's really
what I try to talk about in this book I
talk about coming in with certain SIA
ideals and certain intelligence maybe
and becoming indoctrinated that the
culture that sort of consumes you after
a time what that does to you and how it
changes your perspective my perspective
is this
I admire law-enforcement officers
because I think they they offer a great
deal to society altruistically at least
initially but they're human beings and
things happen to human beings when they
live in a really tough environment day
after day after day the men that I
worked with on the hostage rescue team
and I say men because as of yet there
haven't been any women there maybe
someday but there haven't been yet but
the men that I worked with on the
hostage rescue team came into the FBI
from reasonable degrees of
accomplishment in previous careers I
mean most of the people that come into
the FBI have a law degree have a CPA
have a master's degree a language
specialty or something because it's
quite difficult to get in and they bring
that intelligence to the hostage rescue
team a hostage rescue team looks to FBI
agents who have three or more years of
experience and they try to find people
have some degree of athleticism and some
shooting ability but what they really
bring back is a decision-making ability
because quite frankly here's what HRT
does god forbid something happens in
this room we're held captive by say
three or four people terrorists hostage
takers bank robbers that are looking for
a place to hide out whatever it may be
and they call them in ultimately they're
not called in here the abbé the hostage
rescue team isn't called in here to
shoot they're called in here to save us
that's the bottom line
in doing so they may be called in to
kill someone I mean that's also a bottom
line so they have to be decision-makers
that can run in among a crowd like this
and see a weapon standing next to you
sir and shoot the person with a weapon
even though you're the person that's
running toward them diving at them
because you want to be saved or even
though you're the person that an act of
bravery has reached out to this
terrorist and grabbed ahold of him tried
to wrestle the gun away from him they've
got to decide whether you're the one
with a gun or whether
they're the one with a gun which to
shoot and which not to shoot that with
explosives going off and the doors
caving in and flashbang grenades going
off all around and smoke and screaming
all of that becomes a very very tough
situation to deal with and I think that
most of the guys on HIIT take greatest
pride in being able to differentiate
between those things concentrate on the
job in doing that now if you can call
that intelligence I I don't know I'll
say this two of the guys I worked with
on a chai tea had PhDs a large number of
them were attorneys like yourself a
large number of them including my last
sniper partner had a CPA in fact when I
entered when he introduced himself to me
he was wearing an 18 gold 18 karat gold
Rolex president which I was completely
blown away because I can't afford an 18
karat gold president and and this guy's
coming on a chai tea as a sniper he'd
come as a controller for a fairly large
corporation and had an extraordinary
pedigree as an accountant and or as a
fly as a financial manager and I thought
well how did he end up here I thought
this is quite odd but when you look
around though people don't really want
to believe this when you look around you
say that over and over again where did
this person come from where did that
person come from and the bottom line is
that they start with a reasonably good
pool and I'm the mud among them I should
say that right off the bat I didn't have
any of those things I'm not a lawyer I'm
not a CPA I didn't have a master's
degree until after I went in the FBI I
didn't have any of those things so they
have you know a certain number of people
who sort of fall through the cracks like
myself but you also have some
extraordinary people that do some
extraordinary things so you know in
terms of what happens over time yes to
answer questions certainly they buy into
the culture certain to you know the law
enforcement does certain things to your
perceptions but I think they start with
a sound mind and I think they cultivate
that through education while you're in
and I think they encourage good
decision-making and that's what I think
separates this group most specifically
from from any other that I've worked
with
too long an answer yes sir
is there a difference in the manner in
which the FBI treats domestic issues
like Ruby Ranch or Waco versus what
would be considered international
terrorism is there a difference between
the way the FBI and a chai tea treat
domestic and international terrorism and
the answer is yes I think no one would
really argue that Waco or Ruby Ridge
with terrorist acts but they were
perceived as as huge events and I think
HRT is reserved for that tier of
criminal enterprise that extends beyond
what local or state law enforcement can
respond to and here's the short take on
this if I'm capable of such a thing that
if an event happens in a community it's
gonna be resolved by the local police
department if it can be let's say you
start with a bank robbery okay it's
going to be resolved by the local police
department well I won't use bank robbery
because that's ultimately a federal
offense let's say yeah let's say someone
finds a bag on the corner out here and
under these times of heightened security
they call the local police department
the PD shows up an officer on the street
examines it decides to call the bomb
squad because he or she doesn't have the
expertise to deal with it
the bomb squad comes the technicians
look at the package say it may be a bomb
they back off it exceeds their
capability because they saw some things
that suggest a nuclear or a chemical
capability or something like that and
they call in the state can DC let me
back up again let's say it's in Virginia
they call them the state authorities
they look at it it exceeds their
abilities they call the FBI now looking
at a possible terrorist attack we're
looking at something much that has gone
up in complexity and danger level to a
higher tier they call the FBI and the
FBI is going to respond with its
resources if that response includes a
threat of violence they're going to call
in the hostage rescue team and they're
going to wait for something to happen
within the United States you have all
the all the constraints of the freedoms
guaranteed under the Constitution you
have all of the rules of evidence
gathering of Criminal Procedure which
you have to abide by in order
bring a successful prosecution but now
if we move overseas we can look at a
very different set of circumstances and
I think every well actually maybe most
of you don't know that in the United
States and I'm not an expert on this but
I know a man who is I don't know if he's
gonna help me out with this or not but
in the United States if you want to go
insert something if you want phone
records if you want information there
are provisions you have to get a court
order you have to get a search warrant
in order to get that information when
you're dealing with a national security
issue the standard is a bit different
because I think because of the stakes
the difference that a fair
representation so when you deal with
things overseas especially with
intelligence gathering organizations
they may have a different standard of I
don't know if I want to say
accountability may be a burden of proof
would that be a fair representation that
they have a different burden of proof
and that they have an enormous
consequence so I might be able to get a
wiretap in a national security
investigation for a communication that
it would take me much that it would be
more difficult to get in a civilian
excuse me in a in a domestic thank you a
domestic investigation okay those basic
differences amount to part of the the
overall consideration another part is
that when we go overseas we're probably
doing something very different now I
went to Kosovo a couple years ago and
excuse me that that I think it was a
year ago this last summer it was a year
as a year ago this last summer went to
Kosovo at the request of the
International Criminal Tribunal for the
former Yugoslavia who was trying to
prosecute bring to justice and prosecute
Slobodan Moskvitch who now is going
through just that we went there we the
FBI went there with a team gathered
evidence in a foreign country carried
weapons in a foreign country brought
that evidence back to the United States
gave it to The Hague and offered it as
evidence to be used in an international
tribunal which
it's fairly unusual to do that and I
think most of you would agree when we
went through the East Africa bombings in
in tanzania and kenya dara solomon in
nairobi they had a very unusual
situation there as well because we had a
terrorist attack on the United States
citizens in a foreign country we went
into that country conducted an
investigation and are bringing the
people responsible for that crime to
justice in the United States Yemen I got
back about a year ago from Aden Yemen
where we spent five weeks investigating
the Cole bombing we went over there went
into a sovereign country with weapons
conducted an investigation and are now
trying to bring the people responsible
for that crime to justice in the United
States not The Hague so the FBI in the
last probably five years has expanded
beyond what it's done in all of its
history to reach out all around the
world either through these renditions
that I talked about in getting
konzi and Yousef and all of these people
back to the United States or prosecuting
people and then bringing them back we're
reaching out now we're worldwide and
they and they are very different
networker yes sir
particularly in Yemen
you must depend on obviously some other
outside sources for a lot of language
and translating because I'm sure you're
not all fluent in hundreds of languages
but no you know that's a very good point
that we yes get there in five weeks and
got the evidence either either there was
a lot of evidence there or there was
other people who are very cooperative
what I understood in that two good
questions first you may have to remind
me of the second one in a second but but
the first is that we have some language
capability we don't have enough
obviously when we went to Yemen we went
with language speakers native language
speakers who did the translating they're
FBI agents and they were FBI support
personnel linguists who could speak Arab
Arabic and in a various dialects that
that we ran into you know throughout the
Middle East and they conducted most of
the conversations with people who did
not speak English and many of them did
speak English the FBI certainly has
language resources obviously does not
have enough language resources and
sometimes we have to apply I have to
rely on other intelligence agencies for
that so the shortened areas short answer
is when we went to Yemen we have enough
people that spoke the language and and
that made it a little bit easier in
terms of gathering evidence the further
I went for five weeks others stayed
there much longer than that
and were they cooperative this is tough
now because I don't want to tread
politically on ground I shouldn't
probably but I think it's important to
note that lots of times the United
States and countries consider
cooperation along different lines my
personal interpretation is that we went
into the country of Yemen in military
aircraft carrying m16s carrying handguns
and carrying enough ammunition to do you
know to to protect ourselves
I can't imagine another law-enforcement
agency calling up the president United
States and saying mr. Bush we want to
bring our investigators over the United
States about 65 or 70 of them and we're
gonna bring our own machine guns I can't
imagine that happening so when we go in
there the fact that they allowed us in
to begin with was an extraordinary step
of
gesture of goodwill I think what we
found when we got in there was that that
gesture of goodwill led to a great deal
of skepticism and of probably a fear
maybe rightfully so so they kept an eye
on us so closely that we couldn't do
anything I mean I I think we spent the
first ten days in the hotel and couldn't
leave at all I mean couldn't go outside
the hotel the first ten days I was there
i sat in this hotel while we were
surrounded by the Yemeni military and
and couldn't leave that was very used
unusual and that was hard to get used to
when we landed our plane coming into the
Aden Yemen all right excuse me the aid
in the airport which is one of I believe
only two international airports in the
country they locked on our plane with
surface-to-air missile radar and
prompted the pilots to use electronic
and physical countermeasures which
became a problem later on so you have
degrees of cooperation they felt they
were cooperating with the United States
government and there's no doubt in my
mind that that they that they believed
that they were cooperating but when you
get in the United States government has
a tendency to go into situations like
this and say hey we'll take over from
here
don't worry about it and you can't do
that in a foreign country so what you
what becomes a real interesting play
that I've not heard much discussion of
is that the role or the difference
between the FBI reaching out in a law
enforcement capacity around the world
and the State Department which has
already exists in a in a diplomatic and
facilitative capacity around the world
and bringing the two of them together so
it's not always just an issue of whether
we get along with the government it's
oftentimes an issue of whether we get
along with our own agencies because we
went in there to solve a crime to bring
these people to justice and the State
Department existed there to try and
foster goodwill and in diplomatic
relations with that country so it
becomes very complex and once against
again I've rambled probably a little bit
more than I should but I think
ultimately it comes down to the fact
that they many many countries try very
hard to cooperate with the United States
but sometimes it's it's tenuous okay you
said you went this was this was a
essentially an attack on a United States
ship and you see you went in there to
solve a crime do you see that this
metamorphosizing from being simple
criminal acts to something greater than
that yes I do do I see this changing
from a criminal act to something more
than that you know when you come from my
background 15 years in law enforcement
something like that has to be
characterized as a criminal act I mean
I'm used to finding something happening
trying to investigate it and trying to
help prosecutors put these people in
jail that's the bottom line
do I see there's a crime yes when we
talk terrorism we're taking it up a step
a bit to what we witnessed last week
where you have what's pretty tough to
argue is not and a direct attack on the
United States I mean we didn't call
Pearl Harbor a terrorist attack it was
declaration of war under different
circumstances because we were the world
was at war to a certain extent but now
we have a situation where we say when
does it become when does it go from
crime to military action and I think we
haven't discussed that much in this
country to this point so it's a
fascinating distinction that I think you
bring there and I really don't have an
answer for that yes sir
the US ambassador lady you all had a
pretty horrible ru question was we the
FBI and the Ambassador mrs. Bodeen had a
terrible argument going on who won that
argument and I and I'll say two things
should she ever listen I think very
highly of her she's a brilliant woman
and I don't say that for political
reasons because I'm out of the FBI now
and I don't give a doggone one way or
another but I did find her enormous ly
engaging she's very very bright and
she's very very dedicated and she's a
patriot the problem is the the United
States government brought another wing
into Yemen with with all these weapons
and with all these expectations and
demands and that made it very very
difficult for her to do her job so now
you have the Ambassador who really is
the United States highest interest in
that country without question and you
have a law enforcement agency saying
look we need to bring these people to
justice we need to take these people
back to the United States with evidence
we can use in a way that makes sense to
a film to a federal court in the United
States other countries and I'm not going
to comment specifically on Yemen but
other countries allow interview
techniques that we don't use in this
country we seldom use cattle prods and
very seldom use water torture and
various other things that are that are
accepted I mean I don't think it's a
secret I think it's Waddle written that
in Israel it's perfectly acceptable to
shake interview subjects now I'm not
talking about beating them to death but
that's an acceptable and interview
interrogation technique we can't do that
in the United States so if we go into
another country we may not be able to do
the same things they can so if we want
to go out and do an interview in Aden
for example and talk to these people we
can't necessarily do it the way the
amenities would do it because we may not
be you be able to use the information
gathered during that interview in a
federal court in the United States so
what happened to answer your question is
that mrs. Bodine had certain
expectations as the United States
diplomat and the FBI had certain
expectations as a law enforcement agency
and it just took a time to bring those
expectations in law
and I'm not sure that they ever came
perfectly into line so who won I think
mrs. Bodeen is still there on the job
and doing quite wonderfully at it and
the FBI has has pulled out and and
worked this thing from a different angle
so look we're all in this game together
and I'm sure neither of these two
interests think that they won and lost
that we're all doing the same thing
together but quite frankly that doesn't
always work out just perfectly and
that's what we're working toward in the
future it's not a fair question without
being too diplomatic thank you yes ma'am
are all ethnic groups you know I mean
Arabs Moslems Chinese are they all
represented in the FBI or is the FBI
still I mean I gather there aren't very
many women so that's interesting because
you know we're still dealing quite
frankly and reeling from j edgar
Hoover's legacy and it's widely known he
didn't hire female FBI agents until what
72 or 73 or something like that
there's the early 1970s which boggles
the mind look the FBI investigates
crimes in the United States how do you
investigate crimes in the United States
with people who don't match the
population that baffles me I don't
understand that now we're saying we're
investigating crimes around the world we
have to have people who match the
population we're all Americans it
doesn't matter what we look like you
know we're all doing the same job and
I've heard this this question over and
over again what do we do about racial
profiling and what do we do about people
who look of Arab extract in the United
States you know there's well publicized
crimes of violence against people that
have a certain appearance excuse me and
I'll just say this in Aden Yemen I
worked with two FBI agents who struck me
as two of the most heroic agents I've
worked with and I'm like in all my years
and I and I'm taken into consideration
hostage rescue team operators and
everybody else these two people were of
nerve extract is that fair they're Arab
Americans they both stroke with strong
Arabic accents and I'm not sure that
English was their first language quite
frankly they both looked quite obviously
Arab and they could be mistaken for it
you know
for any of the people that brought down
these planes these two agents risk their
lives over there going against these
terrorist groups bin Laden in Islamic
Jihad and Hamas and all these other
groups trying to bring these people to
justice these two men this man and this
woman one one of each as a matter of
fact could be walking down the streets
of New York of the streets of Washington
DC and have somebody throw a rock at him
and call them a name install you know
some some racial slur at them when
they're the very people who were trying
to keep us from getting killed to begin
with so when I hear stuff like that it
makes me angry I mean it makes me very
very angry because you don't know just
because I love the way someone looks
whether they're out there working on the
front lines trying to protect us or
whether you know you have some mistaken
representation that they get a mistaken
idea that they're gonna cause a crime so
I get very upset about that I really do
but can answer your question the FBI now
has representatives from virtually every
group you could imagine because they're
shopping for that but because quite
frankly Americans apply to the FBI and
you're an American you're a female sir
you're an American you're an African
American and we have in this room alone
we have many different ethnic
backgrounds represented those people are
us we're it just because you're male a
female or you know one color doesn't
mean anything and the FBI has gone to
extraordinary lengths I think in trying
to attract these people into the FBI
it's taken time and we're what we're a
long ways away from that but that's
certainly the idea and and I hope people
remember that when when they when they
see somebody on the street they may
represent their their interest just
because of the way they look
yes sir
that these people are getting onto an
airplane until they properly identify
themselves would they would it not be
proper to give them a second look we
read a story in The Washington excuse me
in The New York Times on the train today
coming back down about a flight
attendant on one of the first flights
out of a domestic airport after the ban
was lifted just a few days ago couple
days ago actually and in this flight
attendant said look you know I felt I
feel badly saying this memory I feel
badly saying this but they walked up to
the to the lavatory near the cockpit try
the door it was locked they stood
outside the cockpit and this flight
attendant just yelled at them started
yelling at them excuse me let me back up
a second they were seek and they had a
turban they yelled at them to sit back
down in their seat and felt very badly
afterward that they'd made that
representation right off the bat we're
human beings everyone has some bias and
disposition not necessarily in a
president prep prejudicial sense but you
may feel certain things they felt
threatened in that situation and it's
very tough to tell someone that their
that their gut instincts are wrong but
they but the bottom line was that they
recognized that very quickly and they
understood that that was an unfair
representation and that wasn't the case
so my answer to your question directly
is that we talked about profiling we
talked about criminal profiling racial
profiling all these different things
there is a big difference between
profiling someone that is driving down
the highway that may have drugs in their
car that lots of local law enforcement
agencies use and the type of profiling
the guys I worked with down in Quantico
used to identify criminals and they're
not the same thing
profile in the first instance talks
about people that you can say well based
on certain crimes we think that
statistically this person looks like a
certain whatever it's terribly flawed
oftentimes not statistically realistic
in any way and it's continuing and it's
oftentimes proven to be complete bunk
and it's been you know drummed out of
virtually every law enforcement agency
that I know of or it's certainly in the
process of that on the other hand you
have a certain group of people better
known as behavioral analysts who look at
behaviors not in color not in ethnicity
not at religious background none of
those things they look at behaviors and
demonstrations of those behaviors and
they use those project things about
future behaviors so you'll take a crime
scene for example and you'll say we have
a crime scene that has certain blood
spatter platted patterns where they've
done certain things to the victim
they've left things they brought weapons
in they found weapons on the scene they
left a certain way they broke in they
didn't break in they tied up the person
with a phone cord all of these things
they look at vast amounts of data
compiled in other crimes and they look
at various things they've learned
through psychological examination of
personalities and they say based on
these behaviors were these
demonstrations of behaviors we can
project that the suspect will be X Y & Z
and they've had extraordinary success in
doing that extraordinary success and
again I could use examples if you want
to go into those but they're very very
different so how does that deal with
with your question when you go into an
airport and you have to make a
determination if someone's gonna go on a
plane and commit a terrorist act I don't
know that's possible because you're
dealing with huge numbers of people I
talked to a gent the other day that said
we had 40,000 flights a day in the
United States 20,000 takeoffs and 20,000
oh I don't know he said 40,000 flights
during a 24-hour time over the United
States which seems remarkable to me but
that's what he said
how are you gonna scream 40,000 flights
with an average of 200 people on each
flight using any sort of profile
whatsoever you're not so you have to
control what goes on the plane in terms
of weaponry because if I go on a plane
and just stand up and say I'm hijacking
the plane people will subdue me probably
beat me into submission and stuffed me
under a seat until we get back down till
I can be arrested but if you go on to a
plane with a knife you have grand
tragedy in the making and then I'll say
this I flew back Monday night before
last before last Tuesday Monday
before the bombings I flew back from
London on a 747 and I was sitting 3 rows
behind the cockpit and I spent a lot of
time on planes both flying and when I
was on the hostage rescue team
practicing with taking hijackings
because because that's one thing they do
is the work hijackings so I'm sitting in
the seat and they brought my dinner
which was quite nice and I gave me my
silver which included a steak knife and
I and I picked up this knife and I
looked at it in my hand and I looked
around and I saw everybody else had one
that had to say meal and it was a steak
knife it had an extremely sharp edge it
had an extremely sharp point and it was
long enough that I could have done
terrible things with that knife which I
thought in my mind long before this you
know 1218 hours before this happened I
thought how could they hand these things
out on planes because I'd only seen the
soft butter knives which wouldn't
threaten mind it much of anyone so I
thought well this is really odd so I'm
sitting on my seating in eating my
dinner and all of a sudden the door to
the cockpit opened up and just stayed
opened up and I could look right into
the cockpit and I saw the gents lie in a
plane it happened to be two male pilots
and in the engineer and so I thought
well this is really odd too and then I
saw the flight attendants bringing
people from the plane up to go into the
cockpit they'd walk around in a cockpit
at 35 40,000 feet high or high we were
they'd walk around and then he'd go back
they came they collected the silver I
gave up my steak knife I hope everybody
else did too I think they did and I was
waiting we start the descent they bring
somebody else in they set him in the
cockpit and they put him right behind
the pilot in the chair right behind the
pilot in the 747 and left the door wide
open now not only could somebody walk
into the cockpit there sitting in the
cockpit and they seemed to be a bit of a
you know a kindly lady she didn't look
like a terrible threat to me so I didn't
get too wound up about it but um I
thought on the way down how hard would
it be to stand up dive over the pilot
hit the yoke and splash 350 people into
Dulles Airport that that that kind of
thing is overboard in the wrong
direction
we can't screen everybody going on a
flight we cannot possibly control every
aspect on a plane but we can do things
like lock the door we can stop giving
people steak knives and we can
things like that yes a bit too and
that's the that was the one thing that
came to my mind is since you said you
had a lot of training on playing Smith
you see anyway those doors could be made
more secure that they couldn't be kicked
in absolutely absolutely
easily without massive has as excellent
security to the cockpit that's not a big
deal I mean the pilots can get out of
there if they need to and use the
lavatories or get a cup of coffee or
whatever they need to do domestic
flights in the United States aren't
longer than five hours anyway I mean
it's you know maybe a little a little
longer than that going coast-to-coast
sometimes but not much longer than that
and and then that's not a problem I
can't imagine anyone would argue that's
a problem and you can make a plane any
way you want you could put a steel vault
in the middle of a plane if you want to
so you could easily harden the bulkhead
to the cockpit and you could make that
simple solution this wouldn't happen
well I think that's a pretty reasonable
argument sure I think that's a really
reasonable argument you know planes that
planes are tough there's no doubt about
it everyone talks about the marshal's
program the sky marshals program which
was done away with quite some time ago
or you may not know is that every
domestic flight in the United States is
extremely likely to have an armed person
on board anyway because anytime an FBI
agent an ATF agent a B a TIA excuse me a
a DEA agent any federal law enforcement
agent and there are many many that you
probably even haven't even heard of
anytime they get on a domestic United
States or a domestic US flight they are
carrying a weapon so they're not sky
marshals but if somebody pulls out a
knife and threatens to commit an act of
terror they certainly have the ability
to respond
I found it extraordinary absolutely
extraordinary that those four flights
not from the East Coast bound for the
west coast and didn't have a single law
enforcement officer on any of them it
was just it was a freak thing I think in
my 15 years I think I've flown on very
few flights where there wasn't another
offer another officer on board with a
weapon because they tell you you know
who each other are you know I mean I
know if there's somebody else on the
plane so so that really surprised me
trying to put sky marshals on 40,000
flights a day working three shifts and
time off for holidays and vacations and
stuff like that you're talking about the
largest police force in the history of
the world
one and you're talking about a distinct
problem in the sense that if you shoot a
handgun in a pressurized cabin you've
got problems that make the terrorists go
away in a hurry I mean they make
ammunition that that could do you know
could do less damage but still you've
got a major problem doing that anyway so
my short answer is that that is a
solution that makes sense on paper it
sounds good when you hear it on the ABC
news or something like that but when it
comes right down to it it's not as
simple as that
it's gonna take more than just putting
sky marshals or a plane just to put sky
marshals on planes that that alone won't
do it yes sir
it's come to light as a result of the
World Trade Center bombings that one of
the massive failures that led to this
occurrence was the lack of intelligence
gathering capability especially the
Central Intelligence Agency but as the
week has progressed clues have been
emanated do the news broadcasting that
the FBI has been warned to several
countries that there could have been
something like this oops your comment
about a terrorist arm could probably
identified some
pattern detector might uh generate some
action in a preventive matter but where
does the excluded the human intelligence
element was there any other failures
that occurred in possibly coordination
between the CIA and FBI especially as we
look at clues there arising from within
the boundaries of the United States okay
the question was about close
excuse me about breakdowns between
intelligence gatherers the FBI where the
information goes yes clearly they were
breakdowns is no doubt about that when
you look at the breakdowns it makes a
little bit better sense the United
States has a number 13 primary
intelligence gathering agencies which
include the FBI most of which are many
of which most people don't talk about
common way I mean everybody knows about
the CIA maybe many of you probably work
for the CIA or the FBI or some of these
agencies I don't know but in in dealing
with the information they gather you
present a staggering problem in
assimilating all that data I could know
absolutely everything going on in the
city of Washington DC right now the
intimate details of each of your lives
and everything about traffic patterns to
book sales in the store but if something
came up and I had to reach into that
giant grab bag of information to find
the few bits and pieces that might
actually prevent a crime there's no way
I could do that it would take too long
to do that with the existing ability to
mine that data so you may have we may
monitor a million phone calls an hour
worldwide but you have to find out which
of those million conversations is gonna
mean something to the president United
States five seconds from now and that is
what's hard so getting from the CIA to
the NSA to the FBI to some other group
takes some time and it's very very
difficult to do that even when you have
that information I saw a story today
that the jet or that the military jets
scrambled and went eight minutes away
from intercepting the planes that hit
the World Trade Centers well you have a
simple logistical problem of getting
these assets and bringing them to bear
even with the best of intelligence you
have reports that the FBI had two of the
names on the list of people aboard these
planes who were believed to be
terrorists and you may say well how's
that happened and I and I'd point out
that there's a list of 10
FBI fugitives who we want more than
people can believe the top ten fugitives
and there are thousands more like them
in the United States and a free society
you can't find everyone immediately and
if there were two people on that board
that the FBI claimed that the FBI was
looking for as tragic as it sounds you
can't always find everyone just in the
time you know specifically when you need
them so clearly we we had problems with
intelligence and breakdowns but but
ultimately you have to look at the
staggering responsibility of these
organizations and say how do we bring
those resources together how do we
develop new technologies that allow us
to mine data from them very quickly for
the really important stuff to rise to
the top and so that everybody can get
this information and we're definitely
working in that way but clearly not
there yet
I am told it was note here because I
talked too long I don't have time for
one more question too quickly yes sir
it's so difficult to freeze than wattens
assets
short answer is I don't know I really
don't know the answer to that question I
know in dealing with international money
enterprise it's much easier now than
well I don't know maybe it always has
been but I know it's very very difficult
to track things because different
countries have different reporting and
accounting rules and it's widely known
that many corporations do business in
Switzerland or an offshore banking
because they have different privacy
requirements and regulations and it
makes it more difficult to get in and
find out detailed information about a
person's finances so it's easy for us to
say now hey we should have known about
his money but quite frankly if it's my
money and I've already paid my taxes I
wanted to stay my money and I don't mind
having some protections so once again we
get into that civil civil excuse me
civil liberties question saying at what
point do we draw the line and right now
we're sort of trying to define that line
thank you very much I really appreciate
the questions I'll only say this because
I didn't talk so much about specifics
specifically about cold zero but I deal
with the vast majority of the things
that we talked about tonight in the book
and in some detail and specifically the
last chapter which projects a crisis
very much like what happened in in New
York and talks about the specific
response and it and it talks in great
detail about how that happens and when
that happens so I thank you very very
much for coming out tonight it's very
kind of you